[Música]
[Aplausos]
una turba furiosa ataca una iglesia
golpea a policías y destruye una estatua
de la Virgen María
este video fue grabado en una iglesia
católica en narayan Pure en India es el
último ejemplo de una ola de violencia
contra las minorías religiosas en ese
país nuestro observador realizó un
trabajo de investigación sobre la
violencia contra la comunidad cristiana
en esa región en diciembre de 2022
que fue atacada por una multitud todos
tenían palos en las manos
se ve que van hacia la iglesia y atacan
todas las ventanas y los ventanales
clases estas personas están
influenciadas por la ideología
nacionalista hindú el bjp el balanty
Yaya Nata Party es el partido
nacionalista hindú de derecha que está
en el poder y el presidente de distrito
de ese partido también estaba entre la
multitud
el ataque a esta iglesia no fue un
incidente aislado
durante el mes de diciembre más de 1000
cristianos de 40 pueblos de los
alrededores de narayan Pure ya se habían
visto obligados a huir de sus hogares a
esos cristianos les dieron tres opciones
la primera era convertirse la segunda
era abandonar el pueblo la tercera
opción era enfrentarse a las
consecuencias los cristianos representan
el 2.4% de la población India según el
último censo realizado en el año 2011
para nuestro observador esta ola de
violencia comenzó porque la comunidad
cristiana fue acusada de convertir a los
hindúes
cada año se registran más de 300
incidentes de este tipo en diferentes
partes del país
las sesiones de oración son atacadas los
pastores son atacados
estos ataques aumentaron tras la llegada
al poder del partido de nacionalista
hindú el bjp en 2014 y siguen aumentando
los líderes del partido nacionalista
hindú afirman que se están produciendo
un gran número de conversiones pero sin
datos sin encuestas sin estudios
el gobierno responde adoptando leyes
anticonversión irónicamente llamadas
leyes de libertad religiosa
desde 2018 al menos 10 estados
gobernados por el partido en el poder
han aprobado proyectos de ley que
declaran ilegales las conversiones
religiosas pero muchos afirman que estas
leyes violan la Constitución India y
afectan injustamente a grupos religiosos
minoritarios
[Música]
aquí están las cabezas de cerdo que
pusieron
y este es nuestro lugar de oración
temporal
temporizador estas imágenes fueron
grabadas por un estudiante pakistaní que
vive en daewu Corea del Sur hace dos
años o miembros de la comunidad
musulmana local obtuvieron el permiso
para transformar en mezquita una casa en
donde oraban pero un grupo que se opone
al proyecto ha estado cometiendo actos
islamofóbicos desde entonces
organizaron una barbacoa directamente al
frente mezquita
su principal objetivo es fastidiarnos y
siguen cometiendo este tipo de actos
como la cabeza de cerdo que colocaron el
27 de octubre y que sigue ahí y eso no
ha sido lo único lo han estado haciendo
continuamente con diferentes métodos y
acciones Durante los últimos dos años
cuando pasamos cerca nos llaman
terroristas
también colocaron carteles en inglés
[Música]
también distribuyeron panfletos contra
el islam que divulgan una visión errada
de las leyes islámicas o ese tipo de
cosas en las casas de los vecinos
incluso yo recibí un panfleto en mi casa
[Música]
la justicia ha fallado varias veces a
favor del proyecto de la mezquita y una
comisión de Derechos Humanos declaró
discriminatorios los comentarios de los
opositores por su parte Quienes se
oponen a la mezquita niegan que sus
razones estén relacionadas con el islam
dicen que les preocupa sobre todo que el
proyecto provoque una gran circulación
de fieles en el barrio y que las
celebraciones religiosas sean demasiado
ruidosas
afirman que no es islamofobia Cómo se le
llama a que nos digan terroristas de qué
hablaban esos carteles creo que lo que
dicen es diferente de lo que han hecho
hasta ahora por qué pusieron las cabezas
de cerdo si no está relacionado con el
islam saben que en el islam está
prohibido nunca he recibido
comportamientos islamofobos por parte de
otros coreanos
especialmente las personas mayores
cuando ven mi barba mi atuendo intentan
acercarse a mí
creo que no esperábamos que ocurriera
aquí las dos religiones predominantes en
Corea del Sur son el cristianismo y el
budismo el islam sigue siendo poco
conocido y poco practicado en ese país
los musulmanes representan menos del 1%
de la población y solo en su mayoría
extranjeros
y de esta manera llegamos al final de
los observadores por esta semana si
quiere contarnos o qué ocurre cerca de
ustedes todos nuestros contactos
aparecen en su pantalla en bien o sus
fotos y videos aficionados quizá sea el
próximo observador de Francia 24 Hasta
pronto